what's up everybody welcome to another
QA this kid is all about what I use so
I've been getting lots of questions
about what kind of computer D have I get
questions all the time what kind of
keyboard do you have probably cuz I
pound on my keyboard what kind of
microphone do you have why do you use in
Windows why use an idol what are you
using to film what are you using to edit
all this kind of stuff so let's get to
it so first of all to record any webcam
stuff I use a C a Logitech c920 I think
it is it's okay for some reason I can't
get to be like that's crisp on my face
or like on an item or something I'm
showing as possible and that will
probably show in this video I don't know
why that is because I've had multiple of
these c920 s I've seen other people's
videos with c920 s and they look way
better than mine don't know what I'm
doing wrong so if you know what I'm
doing wrong let me know anyway that's
what I used to record what I used or at
least record video what I used to record
audio is a blue Yeti before that I
actually used a blue snowball and I
liked I just started liking blue product
unfortunately actually the microphone
I'm recording on now this is probably
the second or third video that I've
recorded on it because my previous blue
Yeti died very unfortunate pretty
expensive high quality microphone should
have lasted longer than it did last
about a year and a half luckily even
blue agrees that their products should
last longer they come with a two year
warranty so this bad boy is going home
and hopefully I'll get another one
refurbished or something anyway there's
that but I went ahead and bought the
exact same one because I like the
recording quality the only pretty much
other option for like a night just a
quick easy USB microphone is there's a
razor or something and I'm just not
confident in their products yet so I
just didn't want to buy that two-year
warranty is still pretty good I saw my
kind of decided to stick with blue one
more time if this microphone dies in a
year and a half I will switch so anyways
that's the microphone
trying to think if there's anything else
to record the screen I use xsplit if I'm
on Windows I'll use OBS if I'm on Linux
now here's a problem so part of the
reason why you guys always see me on
Windows is um not because I only develop
on Windows but it's mostly because
Windows is the best place for me to
record it it produces recordings that
don't lag it produces recordings that
don't have any flickering so like for
example when I'm on Linux sometimes the
recording will start to lag and the
audio and video get messed up also for
some reason the taskbar starts to
flicker which if you go watch like the
tensorflow videos it really was a
problem because you're using your GPU
but even when I wasn't using my GPU to
do like processing and stuff it was
still happening and that's really
frustrating so so I just I don't record
in Linux because it just doesn't work
very well and I think it's maybe because
of the maybe multiple monitors an output
I've found that again at least a boon to
doesn't seem to handle multiple monitors
very well so at least not for I'm sure
plenty of people get by with just two
monitors or something like that but
especially if you've got like multiple
graphics cards open in twos like I don't
know and I've tried I've looked to
figure out how to fix that and stuff and
I just can't luckily now I just have one
GPU it's great and back to just damp
down to one GPU now so it's a little
better but still has recording issues
moving along let me pop this off so
someone asked me if I use dual monitors
absolutely not I use quad monitors
actually used to use five that fifth
monitor there actually I've just got
turned off now that's where my cameras
are I just didn't feel like showing the
world where all my cameras are placed so
anyway that's off but normally it's on I
used to use it for my music I would just
put my music up there but since I've
switched to just one GPU now I can only
hook up four monitors so that one GPU
it's very hard anyway this is my new
microphone this is my essential coffee
this is my keyboard a lot of people been
asking about the keyboard it's a
sidewinder X Microsoft Sidewinder
X
or I love the keyboard it's programmable
it has like three modes too so you can
program each mode to do different things
for you
fantastic keyboard they don't make them
anymore as far as I know I paid $50 5-0
for this keyboard if you want to acquire
one nowadays you generally have to pay a
hundred or more dollars I don't think
it's worth that much
I would pay up to $100 for another one
but beyond that I just want the screens
are just typical 1080p screens I would
really like to have a 4k monitor I just
don't have one they're expensive like
300 bucks even I just want like at
nights like 23
I could go with 24 and just replace that
middle one I'd really like that to be a
4k monitor but you know we'll see
anyway onto the computer so I'm just
going to take the front off now so it's
more easier to see everything alright so
here we have everything probably one of
the first two things you'll notice are
the things with lights so first of all
this is the thing in the middle the
coursera thing it's probably really hard
to read but it says Corsair
um that is a the c100 water cooler and
actually that's this up here as well
this is where the radiator is and it
shoots the air through the radiator up
here cools that sends the water back
down here and water cools the processor
a lot of people are nervous about water
cooling I have been using Corsair water
coolers for about six years now I've
used probably about ten of them I had
one uh fail me after about probably two
or three years but that failure was
actually it just stopped cycling like
the actual pump stopped working it's not
like it just spewed water everywhere
I've never heard of a production water
cooler that just spewed water everywhere
they just died and again it was just the
motor that died it wasn't some sort of
connection or anything that failed so
anyway I highly recommend water cooling
the thing that kills all electrical
components
I suppose is water but also heat heat is
what is going to end the life and and
shorten the lifespan of all of your
electrical components so you want to
keep things as cool as possible
the second thing with lights is the
Titan X GPU 12 gigs of VRAM for all your
vram needs not much to say other than a
super-powerful GPU it does pretty much
any game you could ever want and it's
also great for deep learning
moving right along the motherboard
actually let's go back to the GPU the
GPU is EVGA it's obviously an NVIDIA GPU
I have not noticed any quality
difference significantly with any of the
graphics card producers but I highly
recommend NVIDIA GPUs I've only used a
few AMD's but to me Nvidia is the clear
Victor anyway moving along from there
we've got the motherboard is an asrock
x99 pretty much all motherboard
manufacturers have mixed reviews
especially like with like
dead-on-arrival products that just
happened same thing with Ram if you get
like 10 RAM sticks probably one of them
is dead it's just like seems to be the
way things are
so with motherboards it's kind of the
same thing there's a lot of stuff going
on on a motherboard you probably got a 1
in 10 chance of getting a
dead-on-arrival motherboard and that's
unfortunate it's annoying but for at
least for me performance wise I've never
received dead-on-arrival asrock
motherboard I believe it happens to
people but I've never had that problem
also again all of the stuff that I'm
talking about I've used these products
for you know at least a half a decade
and run them 24/7 and really this
computer here it does get turned off at
night mostly because it's a huge power
hog but also I do a lot of my processing
in the cloud now so I don't actually run
at home but there was a time when I had
about 6 not about I had 6 large
computers just like this and I ran them
24/7
in my apartment it was enough to
displace the ambient temperature about
20 degrees
crazy so anyway so yeah so the asrock
motherboards I've just always bought
them because because they've always
performed well for me next up we've got
32 gigs of ram nothing really to write
home about there I this motherboard
actually can go all the way up to 128
gigs of ram just haven't found the need
there's eight slots for ram let's see we
got that it's Audigy sound blaster sound
card there is onboard sound obviously on
this motherboard I just wanted something
slightly nicer I do like it but anytime
you've got like fancy sound cards it's
not fancy sound card but anytime you got
a sound card sometimes things get funky
when you try to play video games or
something like that sometimes you got to
tweak it or get it figured out
especially like if you play like indie
games and stuff like no one's prepared
for sound cards for some reason anyway
that's the only gripe I would have there
let's see what else what else the CPU is
an Intel i7 59 30 K I have always bought
i7 CPUs the i5 2500 K is probably
another really great CPU that one's just
probably maybe the best bang for your
buck that's ever happened from Intel but
I've used the yet I think it was the
2600 K I've had 38 20 KS 3930k and then
the 59 30 K the 3930k I've had about
probably four or five of those the 3820
cave had about four of them and then
2600 K I think about two of those again
all of them were run 24/7 overclocked
about 40% yes water cooled but still
pretty warm and they lasted for years
like you know five six years and they're
still they're still going like no I've
never had anything just die on me they
do lose they seem to lose power a little
bit especially as far as how far you can
overclock them over time you you won't
probably be able to overclock 40% for a
decade but but I have found Intel CPUs
to be just phenomenal there's no way
I don't think AMD will ever convince me
to go to any of their processors because
for GPUs it seems like to me Nvidia is
the victor and for CPUs intelligence the
God so ok anyway other than that I'm
looking here I don't think there's
really anything else I mean it's 850
watt power supply it's you know nothing
to write home about though just it's a
nice power supply doesn't fancy battle
6000 hard drives uh I do like the hard
drive bays here it's super nice and
especially with a case this size there's
actually a lot of space to feed cables
through the back that's what this isn't
this is actually a pretty clean build
for me usually I've got cables
everywhere I've got zip ties holding
them but this one's actually pretty
clean because you can filter them
through the back and the back actually
comes off trying to think of what the
the brand is for this case I'll put up a
picture of the cases I used to always
get that I liked there good good mid
sized case and then this case I'll put
up - I forget who even made this case
anyway that's the computer pretty sure I
covered everything I needed to cover if
I miss some thinner you carries about
something feel free to ask
alright so that's basically everything
except for why idle so first of all
whenever someone asked me what kind of
editor they should use the canned
response I always give is just try a few
editors out and go with whatever you
like best because who cares what I like
best
who cares with some guy on reddit likes
best and who cares what 80% of
programmers like best it doesn't matter
what you should do is try to yourself it
doesn't matter what other people like
the only time it really matters is if
your employer is like you shall use this
editor but I use idle because it's a
simple editor I like the fact that it
doesn't do autocomplete for me I like
the fact that it's not like the greatest
feature featured especially like for
debugging and stuff like that I like
that
because I can go from idle to pycharm I
can go from idle to sublime I can go
from idle to them I can go from idle
idle to nano I can do everything I can
just go into notepad and write code and
it's not a huge like hmm look what do I
do like I
have habits that require me to use
something that has for example
autocomplete and and I personally just
like that you personally might not like
that and that's totally fine like who
cares so for me I just use it because I
think it's simple I do think it's it's
better like I personally think it's
better especially if you're trying to
learn something new or learn Python in
general I think it's better to use a
simple editor but at least from what
I've seen of the Python editors I have
used pycharm I was kind of get a little
bit of a kick whenever someone's like
have you heard of PyCharm like yes
no you know what I haven't heard of my
German yeah I get it I get why people
like it same thing the other thing like
for one editor I wish I could like is
ipython notebooks oh I see that I see
the value in these notebooks especially
when you're doing like data analysis and
stuff I see the value but first I don't
know I can't put my finger on like why I
don't like him I just don't like them
look I'm sorry so in most cases I told
it like I just think like who cares what
editor I'm using but when I do data
analysis stuff when people are like you
should use ipython I understand that one
right but the other ones it's like who
cares what kind of editor someone's
using but anyway I keep trying to - like
ipython
I just don't for whatever reason I don't
know anyway I think that answer is
pretty much all the what I use questions
I've been getting if you have any more
questions of you can feel free to ask
otherwise I will see you in another
video